hello
my name is jin khanya i'm from waters
corporation
today i'm gonna talk about the enhancing
analysis of
v-group vitamins using
acuity premier solutions
i'll start with
the challenges in llc analysis
basically why we developed this new
technology and what technology behind
this
and also we will talk about a little bit
about the challenges in the b vitamins
analysis
and then we will spend more time to show
you what kind of benefit
that this new technology can bring you
in the b vitamins analysis
before we conclude
so molecules tend to adhere to
any exposed surface
the driving force for this can be
electrostatic force
hydrogen bonding or
hydrophobic interactions or other forces
so usually this kind of
adoption
is not a big deal in lc analysis and not
causing any significant problems
but there's one particular absorption
somebody someone call it metal ion
mediated absorption
it can cause a big hazard in llc
analysis
this absorption often occurs to a
phosphor related compounds such as
protein peptides etc
and the driving force for this kind of
absorption can be ionic in actions
or similar to the
formation of the coordination complex
occasion
actually this kind of interactions
between metal and analyze is used in the
imac
i
immobilize metal ion affinity
cryptography for the purification and
separation of proteins of peptides
so the detrimental effect of this
absorption
can be poor peak shape
peak tailing and diminished recovery of
compounds
and results often result in limited
sensitivity and poor
reproducibility in lc analysis
there are several solutions that people
can choose to address the adoption issue
in lc
one is to add the additives to mobile
phase or samples
for example people often use the tfa
in the mobile phase to to
reduce the absorption
problem
also people can alter the mobile phase
like increase ionic strength or change
the ph
to try to eliminate or reduce the
absorption
the limitation
to this approach
is that adding the additives can bring
in additional issues
such as ion suppression
for the mass back
detection
also
the additives sometimes work for a group
of compounds but not
work for other group of compounds so
it's the
analyte specific solution is not a
generic solution
another approach is to use the
alternative hardware materials
people use pek
or pek leaned columns
try to eliminate the assumption
and also people use titanium alloys
instead of the stainless steel to try to
solve the issue
the limitation to the pe clean material
is that it has a limited strength
and is not compatible with some organic
solvents
the use of titanium alloys
sometimes do help to reduce the
interaction between analyze and ion
surface
but it's still a
metal it can have interaction between
the
titanium alloys and analyze
so it's not completely solve the problem
the third approach people can use to use
the passivation or conditioning
so
the positivation using acid can remove
the
metal ions on the surface
but it's often time consuming and could
damage to the system column
and conditioning with the high
concentration of samples of standards
sometimes do help to
to reduce that assumption
but it's a temporary fix and
need to be repeated frequently to
maintain their activities
so there's a need for a more universal
or permanent
solution to this issue
that's why our waters we developed
technology
is called max peak high performance
surfaces
so basically they put a layer on top of
the metal surface
it's an inorganic organic material or
layer
so it can block the um
the
metal surface
and prevent the interaction between the
metal and the analyze
such prevent the
reduce the absorption or eliminate the
absorption
this
material the hybrid
surface material is actually
has the chemical composition similar to
the
base materials used in the bh collar
it has the pathogen bridge synoxin
materials
and it has
it's more hydrophilic than the pek
material
so it's less prone to the hydrophobic
absorption
so we have the acute premier solution
which uh includes the lc and the column
and and the um the fluidic path or the
vertebral surface in the lc system and
also in the collar
is processed with this max p hps
technology
all the variable surface
in the system and in a column
has this uh coating of alcohol has the
hybrid surface that prevents interaction
between the
metal and the analyze
so additional background about the p
vitamins the p advisements
are essential micronutrients
for
normal human metabolic and physiological
functions
it cannot be made by humans itself
insufficient amount so people need to
have abundant supply of these
macronutrients in diet
but for the normal growth and health of
human body
and nowadays the b vitamin is often
enriched or fortified in food for
example in the
infinite formula infinite formula
and
some beverage
and
the cereals they often fortified with
vitamins
and the determination of b vitamins in
food is commonly required
for the manufacturing process to ensure
a consistent
quality of the packaged food and also to
comply with the food labeling
requirement
and also the regulatory bodies also need
to
assess the b vitamin c food for
research or for the regulation purpose
so we um investigated the potential
benefit of using acurate premier
solutions
for the b vitamins
we focus mainly on the peak intensity
peak shape
carryover issue and sensitivity
we also evaluate it
using the real samples
here are the structures of b vitamins
included in our study
as you can see this is the group of
compounds
of a very wide and diverse structure
the molecular weight range from less
than 100 to over a thousand
and this group of compounds contains
different
functional groups
including forceful phosphate functional
group
capacity acid functional group as well
as amine image
etc
the analysis of devices is not easy
there's a number of challenges in the
analysis of b vitamins
and first of all the b vitamin is not
very stable a very sensitive to light
to their ph
and also the other vitamins or metals
can also affect its stability
and the different ph
conditions some of them can degrade very
fast
this
is solubility is also um kind of
interesting
even though this group of compounds is
called water soluble vitamins
but for some of them they have very
limited solubility
for example the biotin have a 0.22
milligram per ml
and for the folic acid it has 0.0016
milligram per meal solubility in neutral
water
and these b vitamins have a lot of
vitamins some of them have
more than 100 vitamins like this in the
natural
product so it's kind of very challenging
to analyze and extract these vitamins
from the from the sample
and it exists in a wide range of
concentration level from micrograms to
milligram per serving
and some of the internal standard is the
more expensive to obtain
there are
many industrial standards of method
available for the b vitamins analysis
this slides these short a little short
list
of a number of aoac in international
official method
and you can see that
this b vitamins usually analyze as a
group
as a individual environment so it's not
analyzed similarly simultaneously for
all the p vitamins
and the number of waters products being
used in the method development of these
methods
here are the experimental conditions
in our comparison study we use two lc
systems
one is security h-class plus
this is part of the conventional
setup
another one is the qrg premier system
this one has the addition
identical
design of this h-class plus but it has
the max peak surface in it
we also use two
[Music]
columns the water is the acuity uplc bh
18 column and acute premier ph 18
columns these two columns are identical
to each other except the premiere column
has the max peak technology
the mobile phases will have 20
millimolar ammonium formate in water
at ph 5.0 as mobile phase a
and the methanol has over phase b
and column temperature is at 40 dbc
and we have the gradient programs list
here
we use the one massback instrument
is a simple t as level mass by
instrument
with these two different setups
this shows the mrm transitions for the b
vitamins analysis
the transition in bold
is the is for the quantification purpose
as i mentioned earlier in our
investigation we mainly do the
comparison studies
we use two llc setups one is called sop
another called hps
the sop representing the lc system and
column
from the conventional
setup
use the stainless steel
surface
it does not have the max peak hps
technology
the hps setup
contains lc and also the column that
comes with the max peak
hps technology
the two lc systems are are identical to
each other except the
premier system has a max peak
hps technology also the columns we used
in order to eliminate the batch to batch
variation in the packing materials the
column we used are from the same
batch packing materials so there's no
difference in the column performance
and in our study we do the side-by-side
comparison
because the
absorption process is a very dynamic
process so we
we
carefully do this
side-by-side compression study we used
the same samples the same sample queue
and also we only compared results from
the corresponding injections in a sample
queue so we want to
keep everything the same when we do the
comparison study
and here's the
some results we obtained in our
comparison study
this one shows the peak period
comparison obtained from sop setup
versus hps setup
for the first seven initial insections
against sop representing the system
the typical conventional system without
the max peak
hpi surface
and the hps setup representing the
system with the new max peak
hps technology
the blue bar
representing the data from the sop setup
and the orange bar representing the data
from the hps setup
and you can see that
the peak areas generated from the hps
setup is always either
equal or higher than the big areas from
sop so higher peak areas is obtained
with hps
also if you look at some of the
environments
the ffn
flavor mononucleotide the feminine
the tpp the theming parallel phosphate
and the prp the production file cram
phosphate you have a significant uh
higher peak periods from the hpi setup
than the sop setup
this slide shows the picture in cycles
calculated from those seven initial
injections
again the blue bar representing the data
from the sop and orange bar representing
data from hps
you can see that most of the b vitamins
have
comparable
peak pairings except the
family which has a significant higher
pigtailing factor
from sop than hps
also the um since the
[Music]
tpp is there's no peak observed with the
isop setup
so there's no dictating calculated for
the tpp with the isop setup
this slide shows the comparison
in the initial injections as well as
after extensive yields of the system
they
call the columns the chromatogram on the
top
is the result from the initial
injections
the green trace
representing the data from the hps setup
and the reality is representing the data
from the sop set up
and as you can see here
a huge difference between the green
trees and the red trees
indicate that the significant
higher peak areas of peak intensities
obtained with a hps setup during the
initial injections period
and then after extensive use what i mean
here is that after at least 50
injections of samples and standards
and the system already be exposed to
analyze
and some of the active
sites on the surface already already be
assassinated with analyze so it's unless
and less of adsorption occurring in the
following injections so in this um
period
the difference between the green trees
and the retrace is becoming smaller
but still you can see that there's a
small difference between the green and
the red traces that indicate that even
after
extensive use and after repeated
injections
the
sop set up still cannot deliver the same
kind of
performance as hps setup
and also for the farming compound you
can see that after the extensive use
still there's a large difference between
between the sa hps setup and the sop
setup and also peak shape is not
not
improved over the use of the system
so let's talk about the sensitivity
here's the
comparison of the chromatogram from a
standard solutions at different
concentrations
range from three pvp to 10 ppm the
compound is fms follicle mononucleotide
the
chromatogram on the right is from the
hps setup and the chromatogram on the
left is from the sop setup
and by the visual inspection clearly you
can easily see that the detection levels
for the for the hpi setup is much lower
than the detection levels for the sop
so a more sensitive detection can be
obtained with the hpi setup than the sop
setup
here's more data about sensitivity and
also the calibration
here is a table listed the lq the uh the
range of conversion
and also the r square for the fittings
for the hps and sop set up for a number
of
b vitamins
as you can see that for some of the b
vitamins comparable results in terms of
alloque is obtained
but for others specifically the
riboflavin the famine
the nicotinamide
the fmn plp
and the 5m thf
3 to 10 times more
sensitive detection can be obtained
from hps than sop
and here is some data for the carryover
investigation so carry over is a common
issue
for the b vitamins analysis
and here we may compare their results
the commandogram on the top the row
c
it shows the chromatogram
from the
injection of a very high concentration
standard at 10 ppb at 10 ppm level the
chromatogram all the
monogram shown here are
normalized to the same scale
so row b which is the middle row
is the black injection chromatogram with
the sop setup right after the injection
of the high concentration standard
you can see that in the black injection
there are some residual peaks left over
from the previous injection this is
carried over
and the level carrier weighs range from
0.03 percent percent 2.1 percent
which is not very high but still um
evident
is still are discernible
the commandogram at the bottom is from
hps set up and you can see there's
nothing no peak appear in these black
injections
so this means that with the hpi setup or
the max peak hps technology
has less form to the carrier issue
and here's some chromatogram obtained
for the standard
using the acuity premier solution
and next is there are some chromatograms
obtained
for the energy drinks and dietary
supplements
and here's some of additional results
for the energy strings
we have
five vitamin b's
in these energy drinks
the three energy string samples
and for energy drink one number one will
also do a spice experiment to assess the
accuracy or recovery of this analysis
and hopefully you can see that for the
energy drink number one
uh we have a spiked the um
cyanobor cobalamin the riboflavin
testonic acid
paradoxin and nicotinamide
and the recovery range from
91
to 107
which is very very good very accurate
we also can see the rsd level in the
determination of these b vitamins
the number range is usually below 7
and
for the standard cobalamins because of
the low concentration the rhd level
is a little bit higher 17 which is very
common at this level
and here is the result for the
dietary supplement so we evaluate the
determination of d vitamins
uh with the actual
one
deep complex damage supplements and also
you can see
the isd and the recovery
for this group of simultaneous
determination of this group of devices
we have the recovery range from
about 80 to 120 percent
which is pretty good for this
simultaneous analysis of this group of
compounds
and risd uh range
less than
approximately seven percent is obtained
so which is which is pretty pretty uh
pretty good
so here's a summary of this
investigation
so the by using the qrd premier solution
which is has the max peak hps technology
we obtain increased peak area or peak
intensity better peak shape
and improve the detection sensitivity
and also we
will observe that
the um the benefit is very significant
during the initial injections of the
initial use of the system but even after
extensive use we still see a difference
between the isop and hps set up
that means that even after extensive
conditioning of the existing
instrument the stainless steel based
instrument
you probably can
reduce the
problem but still
may not achieve the same level of
performance as the hps technology can
bring you
and also we have we noted there's no
carryover observed with the acuity
premier solution
so it
indicates that more reliable results can
be obtained with security premier
solution
and also
during the investigation we found that
significant improvement also observed
for non-phosphate containing compounds
so for example the semi riboflavin
nicotinamide and the mthf
this compound is um
is not phosphate containing compounds
this means that
maybe there's uh the absorption
the metal ion mediated absorbance is
according to a wider range of compounds
and
this solution
could benefit a lot of other analyses in
the foretesting
and the lc
ms analysis of environments using the
qrt premier solutions have been
evaluated with energy drinks and dietary
supplements and excellent accuracy and
repeatability obtained
so this additional information can be
obtained at our
website at the walters.com website so
here leaves a few additional
relevant
application node that we generated
if you're interested you can go to our
website to download this information
and
thank you again for your time